ابتداء من اليوم دخل القرار الاوروبي
بتحديد سعر النفط الروسي حيزه تنفيذ
باستثناءات محدوده وبدا سريان والحضر لكنه
سمح بفتره الانتقاليه للدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي للتنفيذ التدريجي للحظر
وتنطبق للاعفاءات وايضا على المجر
والسلباكيا وتشيك وهي ثلاث دول اعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي تعتمد بشكل خاص على خط
انابيب النفط من روسيا بسبب موقعها
الجغرافي وعدم قدرتها على استبدال
الواردات بسرعه وفي الوقت ذاته فقد دخل
تحديد سقف في اسعار النفط الروسي البحر
حيز التنفيذ ايضا بموجب بهذا السقف فانها
تقديم خدمات غربيه معينه للنفط الروسي
المنقول عن طريق البحر هو امر محظور حاله
بيع النفط فوق حاجز الستين دولارا للبرميل
قرار الاتحاد الاوروبيه هذا بوضع سقفا
لسعر النفط الروسي همم بقفز الاسعار
الاسعار النفط بنسبه 2% خصوصا بعد ان ابقى
الدول التحالف كلاس على اهدافها المتعلقه
بالانتاج